- This episode of LegalEagle
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking on the link
in the description.
Well, it finally happened
Donald Trump's taxes
have been released, or more specifically,
they've been leaked.
And the information contained inside
helps paint a picture of why the President
wanted to hide the
information for so long.
Since at least 2015,
Americans have wanted to know
one thing about Donald Trump's finances,
does he pay taxes or not?
The New York Times has now
answered this question.
President Trump has paid zero taxes
for 10 of the last 15 years.
He paid $750 in taxes the
year he became president
and the year after and even then
it was only because his accountants
wanted him to pay something.
- He didn't understand the code,
nor would he have had
the time and the patience
to learn the provisions.
He knew that we would produce
the lowest possible tax
for him within the law.
- He deducted personal expenses
like $70,000 in hairstyling services,
he paid hundreds of thousands
of dollars to his children
who he was also employing as W2 employees.
And before he became president,
he was hemorrhaging money,
gobs and gobs of money.
So President Trump pays
basically zero in taxes
because almost all of his businesses
operate at a huge loss on paper
where he is perpetually
inflating the costs
and minimizing his income.
President Trump portrays
himself as a populist,
but he operates more like Bernie Madoff,
a guy who cooked the books
to make himself look like a genius
until his entire venture collapsed.
But are these activities
actually tax crimes
that could get President Trump
in legal trouble or even jail time?
Or is it just legal and smart
tax avoidance strategies
by a financial pro working
their magic over the tax code?
Well, we finally have a window
into answering these questions.
(orchestral music)
Hey, LegalEagles, it's time
to think like a tax lawyer
because the President's finances
and the finances of the Trump Organization
are a web of interlocking companies,
all of which appear to use
extremely suspicious tax
and financial strategies.
Now, it appears that The New York Times
has access to the President's
personal tax returns
going back 20 years as
well as the tax returns
of the different Trump Organization LLCs,
of which there are hundreds of them
which are interrelated to the President,
because of their past through nature.
We'll probably cover the
liability of this whistleblower
in a different video, but suffice to say
the information that they
divulge appears to be accurate.
Now, the whistleblowers liability
is an interesting question.
But under the Pentagon Papers case,
New York Times versus the United States,
unless The New York Times
suborned the actual leaking
or the whistle-blowing
and actually facilitated
the actual act of
disclosing the tax returns,
The New York Times
is almost certainly
free to cover the story
and will probably escape
any kind of liability
regardless of whether the person
who actually blew the whistle
and or leaked the information
has personal liability,
which they might.
So the question for the public
is can we come to any legal conclusions
based on the information
that was divulged?
Well, let's start with the tax code.
Title 26, Section 7201 of the tax code
creates the federal crime of tax evasion,
which has historically been
the main tax revenue offense.
There are two potential
offenses under Section 7201.
Subsection 1: The willful attempt to evade
or defeat the assessment of a tax.
And two: The willful
attempt to evade or defeat
the payment of a tax.
The most common attempt
to evade or defeat tax
is the affirmative act
of filing a false return
that omits income and or claims
deductions for the taxpayer
that they're not entitled to.
The tax reported on the
return is falsely understated
and creates some deficiency
and when someone underreports their income
this is an attempt to evade or defeat tax
by evading the correct
assessment of that tax.
To prove these crimes,
the government must prove
that the defendant engaged
in some affirmative conduct
that was designed to mislead the IRS
or conceal the tax liability or assets.
And often this comes in
the form of deductions
that you're not actually allowed to take
or personal expenses that you
say are a business expense.
And when there is a pattern
of overstating or inflating deductions,
the IRS can charge you with tax evasion.
And this may be a problem
area for the president
because for years, President Trump
has classified most of the money he spends
on his lavish lifestyle
as a business expense.
For example, President Trump claimed
the cost of air travel and car services
to and from his private
homes as a write off,
he itemized over $70,000
in hairstyling fees
for whatever is on his head.
He also deduct the expenses
for Ivanka's his hair and makeup artists
to the tune of nearly $100,000.
Hair and makeup deductions
are pretty straightforward deductions.
A haircut or makeup application
isn't deductible unless the use
is limited exclusively to the
business appearance itself.
And that's hard with the haircut
because the haircut lasts
after you have done the
thing that you're doing.
And then there's things like using
an investment property for
your own personal purposes.
President Trump took a deduction
for an investment property
located in Bedford, New York.
This home which the Trump
family called Seven Springs
has been in the Trump family since 1996.
And the Trump offspring have bragged
about spending summers
at the 200 acre estate.
According to the the Trump
Organization website,
"Today Seven Springs is used as a retreat
for the Trump family."
If it's a personal retreat
for the Trump family,
how can it be an investment property?
As an investment property,
Trump has been able
to write off $2.2 million in
property taxes since 2014.
We don't have any evidence
that Seven Springs
is actually being rented out or developed,
which is typically how you
would show that a property
is an investment property
rather than a residence.
Instead, the property is described
by the Trump Organization
website in loving terms
complete with a photo spread,
emphasizing its opulence
and Trump's own tax declarations
also work against this
claim of Seven Springs
as an investment property.
One year after he made the designation
he claimed a tax deduction on the property
for a charitable easement.
A charitable or conservation easement
is another way of creating a tax shelter.
But basically you can give
the government or your
public interest rights
to your property
such as the right to prohibit development
or a property to preserve
the nature surrounding it.
That charitable easement on Seven Springs
precluded from being developed.
And then there's things
like potentially bogus consulting fees.
Companies are allowed to
deduct consulting fees
from their income because
they are a business expense.
This reduces the tax bill
because the income that is taxed
is lowered by the amount
of the consulting fees,
just like any other business costs.
So if Trump's businesses deducted
legitimate consulting fees
that is not by itself tax evasion.
However, the Trump Organization
consistently reports that
about 20% of its total income
was paid to consultants,
and this applies across all projects.
So when Trump made $5 million in income
on a hotel deal in Azerbaijan,
he reported $1.1 million
in consulting fees.
In Dubai, he made $3
million in income on a deal
but reported $630,000 in consulting fees.
These fees, reduce income
and thus reduce income tax.
But on deals where you
don't own the property,
and you're only making money
on the licensing of your brand,
as Trump was doing with
these foreign deals,
the last thing you want is
a huge 20% consulting fee,
unless you're also benefiting
from that consulting fee personally.
It's also suspicious that the
fee is approximately the same
regardless of the size of the deal
and the relative lack
of need for consultants,
but further inquiry would be needed
to get to the bottom of this.
And let's put aside the problematic nature
of a president getting foreign income
from effectively dictatorships,
because there's even
more damning information
involving consulting fees
linked to Ivanka Trump.
Ivanka has a formal position
at the Trump Organization
for which she gets a salary.
But at the same time,
it appears that Trump's company
once paid $747,000 in fees
to an unnamed consultant
for hotel projects in
Hawaii and Vancouver.
Coincidentally, when Ivanka Trump
later filed public
disclosure forms in 2017,
she listed payment for
the identical amount.
So it looks like Ivanka,
an employee of the Trump Organization
also got paid a hefty consulting fee
through a consulting
company that she co owned.
Would this raise a red flag with the IRS?
Absolutely, if Ivanka
received a consulting fee
on the same project that she managed
as an employee of the Trump Organization,
which is what The Times alleges,
this looks like evidence of fraud.
Anytime a company pays a
family member consulting fees
it looks like the family is
conspiring to hide income.
Consulting fees being paid
to family members also looks like gifts.
which aren't deductible and in
fact, if the fees were gifts,
then Trump would have
liability for paying gift tax.
The bottom line is that paying
a family member employee
through a shell corporation
could be a way to avoid gift tax
and a way to avoid payroll taxes.
And it doesn't appear that Ivanka
is the only adult Trump's child
who engaged in shady practices.
That brings us to legal
fees for Donald Jr.
The IRS says that legal
fees can be deducted
when they are directly related
to operating your business,
but this does not include legal fees paid
to defend charges that
arise from participation
in a political campaign.
However, the tax records show
that the Trump Organization
wrote off business expenses
paid to criminal defense lawyers
who represented Donald Trump Jr.
during the Russia investigation.
The lawyer received at least
$1.9 million in 2017 and 2018.
And Trump wrote off about $260,000
paid to William and Jensen,
a second law firm hired
to represent Trump Jr.
As you might recall, a lot
of the Russian investigation
was related to meetings that Donald Jr.
had with people promising
dirt on Hillary Clinton,
so it doesn't appear that this could be
a legitimate business expense.
These are all potential examples
of the most simple form of tax evasion,
deducting expenses as business expenses
that are not actually for your business.
It's possible that some
of these deductions
might be defensible, but it
would be an uphill battle.
Tax experts often say
that it's very difficult
to surmise tax evasion on
the face of the returns,
and that one usually needs to dig in
to the actual expenses and deductions
before concluding anything.
So take The New York Times
analysis with a grain of salt.
But that said, almost
every professional says
that some of the items
in the Trump returns
are so brazen to be
almost certainly improper,
but it's possible for
justifications for them.
Of course, this is one of the reasons
why historically presidents
release their taxes
to avoid even the
appearance of impropriety.
And also on the other hand,
these are only the seemingly
improper deductions
on the face of the returns themselves.
If you actually dug
into the underlying
expenses and deductions
that appeared to be proper,
you might find things that are even worse.
Now, in fairness, these
potentially inflated,
potentially improper deductions
make Trump's businesses
look less profitable
than they might actually be.
And one additional point,
a lot of experts are taking
these returns at face value
since The New York Times is not releasing
the underlying documentation.
But given the improprieties
on the surface,
it's almost certain
that the underlying numbers
themselves are wrong,
to what extent?
We don't know.
Now, a lot of these things look bad,
but it's important to know
that it can be incredibly difficult
to prove the crime of tax evasion.
Because most of these crimes
require the mental state of willfulness.
We talk about mental states
on this channel a lot
because almost every criminal law
requires a certain
mental state, a mens rea,
to prove the crime itself.
And here willfulness is defined as,
"The voluntary intentional
violation of a known duty."
This is known in the law
as a specific intent crime
that comes from the case of
Cheek versus United States,
which is a really interesting
Supreme Court case,
where a tax Professor John L. Cheek,
failed to file tax returns and
was convicted of tax evasion.
But the court held that
his good faith belief
that he wasn't violating the tax law
based on a misunderstanding
caused by the complexity of the tax law,
actually negated the willfulness element.
And that applies even if that belief
is irrational or completely unreasonable.
So this is one of those rare cases
where having a misunderstanding of the law
or sometimes ignorance of the law
actually can be a defense,
which is pretty rare for obvious reasons.
But also note that the court has ruled
that an actual belief that the tax law
is invalid or unconstitutional
is not a good faith belief
based on a misunderstanding
of the tax law.
So that's not a defense.
So sorry for all of you
sovereign citizens out there.
And another thing that's
incredibly important
in this context is what
the tax preparer tells the tax filer,
often people use the defense of relying
on their tax professional
for the advice about
what the tax law is, or is not,
which can also provide a defense.
But the bottom line is
this is a subjective test,
a defendant's good faith belief
that he's not violating the tax law,
no matter how objectively
unreasonable or stupid that is,
can be a defense in some tax prosecutions.
And to try and keep my sanity,
I'm going to try to
refrain from putting myself
in the head of Donald Trump,
and who knows what mental state he had
or did not have when
he was filing his taxes
and claiming all of
these various deductions.
Which brings us to the more complicated
but just as serious potential crimes
under Title 18 regarding a refund.
Tax fraud cases are distinguishable
from those involving false
claims for a tax refund,
which are generally prosecuted
as violations under 18 USC 286,
which is conspiracy to
defraud the government
by obtaining or aiding to
obtain the payment or allowance
of any false fictitious
or fraudulent claim,
and 18 USC 287, making or presenting
false, fictitious, or fraudulent claims
upon or against the government.
The New York Times investigation
uncovered Trump tax refund
which is currently the
subject of an IRS audit.
And President Trump wasn't lying
when he said his finances
have been under audit
for an extremely long time.
And this requires a bit of background.
Trump made his reputation
in the 80s and 90s
through lavish properties and casinos.
However, the business has
lost over a billion dollars
and four of them filed for bankruptcy.
In 1995, Trump declared a tax loss
of more than $900 million
related to his Atlantic City casinos,
and the IRS let Trump offset the profits
of his businesses in the future
by using his past losses.
So you can offset $900 million in profit
using $900 in losses.
The tax loss carryovers from
the casinos came in handy
reducing the Trump
Organization's tax bill to zero
once the company started doing well again.
Now, put a pin in this $900 million loss
because we're gonna come back to that.
But even after the company's recovered
from the casino implosion
it lost big money
on the 15 golf courses that
Trump started buying in 2000.
Trump reported that the golf courses
collectively lost over $315 million.
But were these losses really legitimate?
The Times report says
that from 2016 to 2017,
general and administrative expenses
at the Bedminster Golf Club alone
had increased by five times.
Now, why would business
expenses increase five times
on businesses that were failing
and never generated a profit?
And well, it's possible that someone
purposefully inflated the expenses.
Inflating expenses on a failing business
is a classic money laundering tactic,
which you would know if you've
ever seen the show Ozark.
Now, the prospect of money laundering
is beyond the scope of this video,
but I'm betting that we
haven't heard the last of this.
And I recommend checking out
the reporting of Adam Davidson,
who looks at the Trump
properties across the world.
And what he sees is a continual pattern
of failing businesses
needing a cash infusion,
getting a cash infusion
as a loan from Donald Trump personally,
and then that money basically
disappearing to parts unknown,
which might be money
laundering, we'll have to see.
And not to mention Trump's
incredibly suspicious foreign income.
For example, Trump used to own
the Miss Universe Pageant
which lost millions
in both 2012 and 2014.
But right in the middle in
2013, Trump made millions
because of a one time payment
from the Agaralov family,
Russian billionaires who have
close ties to Vladimir Putin.
A huge one time payment
in a money losing venture
could be an overpayment,
or it could be an effort to
funnel money for another reason.
But what we do know is
with these massive losses,
what saved Trump's businesses
from going belly up
was revenues from The Apprentice,
and a few profits
generated from Trump Tower,
one of the few pieces of real estate
that he actually made a profit on.
And this cash infusion from The Apprentice
was good news for the Trump Organization.
But it also meant that
for the first time ever,
President Trump had a big tax bill,
and Trump had to pay $70
million in taxes and he paid it.
But in 2010, Trump told the IRS that,
oh, by the way back in 2008 and 2009,
his business happened to
lose about $1.4 billion.
Trump claimed that this huge loss
entitled him to a full
refund of the income taxes
he had paid in 2005, 2006, and 2007.
And amazingly, the IRS quickly
paid out this massive refund
over $70 million, and
state and local governments
followed suit giving him back
an additional $21 million.
Trump went from telling the
IRS that he was doing well
to suddenly losing another $1.4 billion.
And where did these heretofore
unknown business losses come from?
Well, remember that $900
million abandonment loss
he suffered as a result of
the Atlantic City casinos.
In 2009 he reported that he abandoned
his disastrous casinos
which filed for bankruptcy.
And when you abandon a business,
you can take a deduction
for some of the losses,
as long as you don't
receive anything of value.
In other words, you
have to truly give it up
for nothing of value in exchange.
And according to IRS Publication 544,
sales and other dispositions of assets,
abandonment losses from
business or investment property
are generally deductible
as ordinary losses,
meaning you get a one-to-one deduction
on all of the losses that you suffered,
as long as the abandonment is not treated
as a sale or exchange
of anything of value.
But The Times reports
and public records show
that Donald Trump actually
did get something of value
in exchange for his old interest
in the bankrupt Atlantic City casinos.
He actually got a 5% stake
in the casinos successor company.
So this tax refund of over $70 million
is being audited and has been audited
for basically a decade.
And tax law actually requires
that all refunds of more than $2 million,
get approval from Congress's
Joint Committee on Taxation.
And that's where this matter
has been stalled for several years.
We don't know exactly why
this has not been resolved,
but the word politics almost
certainly comes to mind.
And recall that for over a year,
we've known an IRS whistleblower
that says a member of
the Treasury Department
tried to interfere
with an audit of Donald
Trump or Mike Pence.
It seems that these two
things might be related.
If Trump loses the audit,
which it appears he should
he'll be on the hook to repay
not just the 72 million,
but also fees and interest
bringing the total to over
$100 million in repayment,
that alone could bankrupt the
undercapitalized president.
So now we get into the meat
and potatoes of the matter,
did Donald Trump commit tax fraud?
Tax fraud is generally not
that difficult to understand,
although there are certainly legal ways
to limit your tax exposure.
We'll get to those in a minute,
and arguably, people are perfectly allowed
to pay the minimum amount in taxes
that they legally have to pay.
There are also clear prohibitions
against lying to the IRS.
Not that President Trump
has ever been caught lying.
But let's talk about
making false statements.
Section 7206 of the tax
code deals with tax fraud
and making false statements to the IRS.
These violations typically
result from a taxpayer
falsely inflating deductions
or underreporting income
on federal income tax returns
to reduce or avoid tax burden.
And a section 7206 felony prosecution
is not limited to tax returns
it deliberately applies
to, "Any return statement
or other document required
by the Internal Revenue Code
or applicable regulations."
Though know that convicting someone
of providing false or fraudulent
information to the IRS
still requires a show in willfulness
which we discussed earlier.
But it can be easier to prove
then outright tax evasion
in the false information context,
but you still have to show willfulness
and under United States versus Clairborne,
neither a showing of careless disregard
nor gross negligence and signing
a tax return will suffice.
But it's not all smooth
sailing for the tax filer.
On the other hand,
willfulness can be inferred
from the rest of the tax documents
and from circumstantial evidence.
And proof of a pattern of
falsity supports an inference
of willfulness under United
States versus Conlin.
And while some have argued
that Trump can't form the
requisite mental state,
because he's so all over the place,
there is a presumption that
you know what's in your taxes
when you sign it.
And liability for lying to the IRS
is not limited to the taxpayer alone
and includes people who
prepared the returns,
corporate officers, and
even tax shelter promoters.
So in the Trump world, many
people could be on the hook
for these returns like
President Trump's accountants.
Allen Weisselberg, CFO
of the Trump Organization
is probably also on the hot seat.
And during a deposition
related to a lawsuit
against Trump University,
Weisselberg said only five
people have the authority
to sign checks for the company,
Donald Trump, Donald Trump Jr.
Eric Trump, Ivanka Trump, and himself.
And you might recall
that former Trump lawyer, Michael Cohen
also set up a shell company
to conceal the hush money
payments to porn stars
and coordinate strategies
with the National Enquirer,
a process that probably
also involve making false statements,
because spoiler alert,
there isn't a line item
related to the payment of stormy Daniels.
So it looks like those
payments tried to be hidden
in normal business operating expenses.
But actual preparation of a false return
is not necessary to sustain a conviction.
Just supplying false information
can be enough in some
cases for conviction.
Of particular interest to Donald Trump
as a real estate magnate
is United States versus
Lefkowitz, where the defendant,
a manager of several real
estate limited partnerships
lied to his accountants
that the projects were pre-leased
to qualified low-income tenants,
and therefore the limited partnerships
could begin taking tax credits
when the units were placed in service.
That guy was convicted because
he gave false information
to the limited partnerships
causing them to file fraudulent returns.
But let's take a moment now
to talk about lawful tax avoidance.
A lot of the President's defenders claim
that Trump is doing what all
successful businesses do,
just exploit legal loopholes
to reduce taxation.
And there's a lot of people who argue
I think, persuasively that
no individual or corporation
has an obligation to pay any more taxes
than they are legally required to do.
And tax avoidance
is just the legitimate minimizing of taxes
and maximizing after tax income
using methods included in the tax code.
And lots of businesses avoid taxes
by taking all legitimate
deductions and tax credits
and sheltering as much income as possible.
This is all legal.
The IRS even has a cheat sheet summarizing
the difference between
avoidance and tax evasion,
which is illegal.
A tax loophole is tax avoidance.
A loophole is usually a
deliberate clause in the tax laws
that legislators created to
reduce certain people's taxes.
And we can argue whether
that's a good idea or not,
but a lot of the tax code is written
specifically to give benefits
to certain groups or individuals.
And since the tax code is so complex,
savvy tax experts have
found ways to lower taxes
for their clients without breaking the law
and taking advantages
of the law as written.
And I have absolutely no doubt
that some of Trump's
deductions were legal,
but the idea that Trump is just a genius
who was acting like
other business geniuses
should probably be scrutinized.
So let's talk about the
actually uncontroversial idea
that business losses offset
the taxes on business profit.
If President Trump
is actually losing lots and lots of money,
and then taking that deduction,
is this really a smart tax maneuver?
Well, actually, no.
But during a presidential debate in 2016,
President Trump said:
- I have a write off a
lot of its depreciation,
which is a wonderful
charge, I love depreciation.
- And that makes sense
because depreciation
allows the owner to take
depreciation deductions
on the property that's
probably still gaining value.
For example, if you own a property,
that's worth a million dollars,
even if it's appreciating in value,
you're allowed to deduct a certain amount
of the value of that property per year.
So if you have a property
on Fifth Avenue in Manhattan, for example,
it may depreciate for tax purposes,
but it'll keep gaining value.
And this is all basic stuff
that you learn even playing Monopoly.
And we can argue over whether
real estate developers
should be allowed to take depreciation
on an asset that actually
is going to exist
for a very, very long time
and is actually appreciating in value,
but that's actually the law.
And that's why inheriting
established properties
in the New York City real estate market
with no debt attached
like Donald Trump did
from his father Fred, can be so lucrative.
You're allowed to take a
whole bunch of deductions
from the physical property of
the real estate in New York.
However, there's a big distinction
between a sensible depreciation deduction
and being forced to take a deduction
because of actual business
losses that you suffered.
Marty Ginsburg, who was the husband
of Ruth Bader Ginsburg was considered
a spectacular tax lawyer and professor,
and he authored a famous article called,
"The Leaky Tax Shelter,"
where he made the point that
the key to a tax shelter
is not actually suffering
the losses that you deduct.
Ginsburg joked that a bad
tax shelter idea was saying,
"Hey, give me a million
dollars of your money
and run away to it with a
country where you can't get me,
and then you have a million
dollar theft deduction."
The point is that your
goal isn't losing money
than deducting the money that you lost.
That doesn't make you a genius
or even particularly shrewd.
Since 2000, Trump lost
more than $315 million
at golf courses like Trump National Doral
and The Washington Hotel
which opened in 2016,
and has lost more than $55 million.
Across the world his golf
courses are hemorrhaging money,
the vast majority of the losses
appear to be real losses,
not magic deductions conjured
up by a financial whiz.
In other words, his economic losses
far outweigh his tax losses.
Trump's businesses are pretty simple,
real estate and licensing,
and he appears to be
exceedingly bad at it.
But as the president
and his adult offspring
employees like to point out,
part of the game is to
show bigger tax losses
than you actually incurred.
So these returns do in fact,
overestimate the losses.
So to the extent that these
are real economic losses
that offset future income,
this is not financial wizardry,
this is just going back to square one,
to go back to the Marty Ginsburg point,
imagine you're at a casino,
which with Trump that's an actual thing,
you start playing blackjack
and you lose $1,000,
then you go back to the
table, and you keep playing,
and you actually win $1,000.
Well, that prior loss of
$1,000 will offset the profit
of the future income that
you have winning $1,000.
But you're really just
back to where you started.
So that's why you're able
to use the prior loss
to offset this "gain" that
you incurred by winning.
And that's essentially
what's happening here.
It's not financial wizardry,
it's just going back to square one.
But it appears from the returns
that Trump's entire business empire
was based on exactly that premise.
He runs up big debts, goes bankrupt,
and then gets to write
off those huge debts
for several years,
then starts the process all over again.
The Apprentice was really
the first time Donald Trump
ever hit a basis clearing
home run in licensing
and making enough cash
to prop up his other failed businesses.
But by the time that he was president,
that money was gone too.
And that's why people are freaking out
about the number $421 million,
because that's how much Donald Trump
personally owes to other creditors.
And people are worried
that this is a national security issue
that the sitting President
of the United States
owes over $420 million to people unknown,
including potentially foreign sources
we don't actually know.
And it appears that most
if not all of those loans
are going to come due in a balloon payment
that will happen if he's
elected to a second term,
which is completely uncharted territory,
that a sitting president
of the United States
will have to negotiate with
creditors, domestic and foreign.
And of course, people remember
that to avoid exactly
these kinds of conflicts,
Jimmy Carter had to put his
peanut farm in a blind trust
to avoid the appearance of impropriety.
And this also raises the
difference between the fact
that a lot of corporations in
United States pay no taxes,
but usually the
individuals, the employees,
and the people that own those corporations
do often pay taxes.
The average tax rate for a
millionaire or billionaire
in the United States is about 25%,
which is lower than the average taxes
that a normal person is going to pay
but still well above the
zero taxes that Donald Trump
has paid for most of his career.
And here Donald Trump's
personal tax liabilities
almost inextricably linked
to the Trump Organization
because they're passed through entities.
So there's a big difference
between a corporation like Amazon
that gets taxed as a corporation
and an LLC, which just
the tax is passed through
to the person or people that own it.
And let's talk about Amazon for a second
because that's an interesting comparison.
Amazon famously pays little to no taxes.
And this appears to be legal.
But this is very different
from what the Trump Organization does.
Amazon is a business that reinvests
all of its profit back into
the business year after year.
So for years, Jeff Bezos
was focused on making Amazon
as big as possible, dominating
the online shopping space
to such an extent that the company
was even able to pressure
brick and mortar retailers
by undercutting their profits.
And the company did this
by aggressively investing
in research and development
and borrowing more and more money
to grow even bigger.
If Amazon had kept more of its profits,
it's reported income would
have been much higher,
and they would be responsible
for paying higher taxes on those profits.
But the Trump Organization appears
to be a different animal entirely.
It doesn't have research
and development costs,
it's not buying more and more assets
to offset any particular profit.
And Donald Trump's main place
have always been in real
estate and licensing.
And it appears that the losses
that he's reporting on his taxes
are actual losses that his businesses
have been suffering year,
after year, after year.
They're not necessarily paper
losses that are offsetting
a whole bunch of revenue in other places,
his businesses are
generating loss after loss.
And in some cases, it's not clear
where the money is coming from
to prop up these businesses that lose
hundreds of millions of
dollars year over year.
And the bottom line is that rich people
do pay less in taxes in the US.
But even still, Donald Trump
should have been paying some taxes
and all the tax avoidance
strategies in the world
still don't make this typical situation.
When asked about the tax returns
at the presidential debate,
President Trump said that
he'd paid millions in taxes.
- I paid millions of dollars in taxes,
millions of dollars of income tax,
I paid $38 million one year.
I paid $27 million one year.
- Show us you tax returns.
- And he might have
but almost certainly not
federal income taxes.
Perhaps he's paid property
taxes or payroll taxes
but not income taxes.
Tax experts say that he
can clear everything up
by releasing a single page of his 1040
to show just how much he has paid in taxes
without divulging more information,
but he's provided no concrete details
to dispute any part of The
New York Times reporting.
And the worst issue
is that many of the President's properties
are being held up artificially with loans.
For many he hasn't paid a
single dime of principle,
and hundreds of millions
of dollars in loans
are coming due in the next four years.
And because the properties are so risky,
Trump had to personally
guarantee the loans,
meaning that even if the property fails,
the creditor can go after Trump himself.
One might be able to refinance these loans
but that's extremely difficult
when the underlying properties
are losing money hand over fist.
And it's completely uncharted territory
for a sitting president to
either renegotiate the loans
or have a creditor foreclose
on the sitting president.
Not to mention the obvious
conflicts of interest.
Nancy Pelosi and other Democrats
have called this a
national security issue.
- He has exposure
to the tune of hundreds
of millions of dollars
to whom over $400 million in leverage
that somebody has over the
President of the United States.
- Some have pointed out that such leverage
often prevents individuals from getting
even a security clearance
for the exact same reason.
- One of the most important things
that the FBI and the
background checks look into
is are you potentially
beholden to anybody,
or any entity, any country
that could use that leverage
against the interests of the United States
in our national security,
in order to extort or exploit
or otherwise manipulate you.
- Though by the same token,
the total assets that President Trump has
are probably worth
enough to cover the loans
if he liquidated all of these properties.
They are not worth what
Trump says they're worth,
sometimes he claims $2.5 billion dollars.
But if you liquidated all the assets,
it would probably be enough
to cover the $421 million
that is likely to come
due in balloon payments
in the next four years.
But this is surprising only to people
who haven't been paying attention.
Recall that the Trump foundation charity
was shut down for fraud.
Trump University paid a
settlement of $25 million
for essentially defrauding students,
though it admitted no fault.
And we already knew that President Trump
owes Deutsche Bank hundreds
of millions of dollars
and The Times investigation
reveals that his business enterprises
are once again on the verge of bankruptcy.
Now, there will inevitably
be people that argue
that Trump's ability to beat the taxman
is just evidence that he's smart.
But recall that tax problems are the ones
that brought down Al Capone.
And nobody ever thought
that his ability to evade taxes
was a qualification for President.
And it's possible the only difference
between Capone and Trump is
that Capone went to prison
while Trump went to the Oval Office.
But that doesn't mean that President Trump
couldn't use a refresher
on what it takes to run
a successful business.
After all, he's lost billions of dollars
stiffed banks and contractors,
and had many businesses go bankrupt.
But the best place for him to brush up
on his business acumen
isn't Trump University,
it's Skillshare, which offers classes
on how to manage every aspect
of new business ventures.
Donald Trump has a lot in
common with freelancers
who are struggling to
understand the US tax code
and the class, Bookkeeping
For Freelancers,
how to handle your
finances by Emily Simcox,
will really demystify the tax season
for Trump and anybody else.
The class teaches students
on how to choose the
right bookkeeping method,
how to categorize and track expenses,
and how to stay organized
throughout the year
even in years you're being
impeached or audited.
Simcox breaks down the ins
and outs of bookkeeping
into terms that even a graduate
of Trump University could understand.
Trump could also benefit
from Guy Kawasaki Skillshare class,
Art of the Start, turning ideas
into high growth businesses.
So you can actually start
a money generating business for once.
Skillshare as you know,
is an online learning community
that has 10s of thousands
of classes on everything
like illustration, creative
writing, music and productivity.
The first 1,000 LegalEagles
will get two free months
of Skillshare premium
when you click on the
link in the description.
And after the trial ends Skillshare
is still way more affordable
than most online learning platforms
with plans starting at
less than $10 a month.
Plus clicking on the
link in the description
really helps out this channel.
So just click on the
link in the description
to get two free months of Skillshare.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Do you think President Trump
is a tax cheat or a tax genius?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other law reviews
of the current legal issues
including lots of stuff going on
in the Trump administration.
So just click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.